okay okay I'm just I'm just giving you
the answer to the question you're asking
all night long on Friday night Stephen A
Smith uh and Adam shiff so the fact that
God bless Bill Mah I'm going to text you
after the show stop putting this freak
on the show he's evil he's awful these
people Stephen A Smith and Adam shift
got into it about about whether
Republicans want to stop people from
voting allog together bottom line is
this I respect the fact that you don't
share my pessimism I truly do I
understand where you're coming from but
I think that's part of the problem I
think the Democratic party should share
my pessimism I think they should be on
high alert I think they need to to treat
him with the seriousness that it
deserves because you're you're have you
having a lot of faith in the American
people the man did get over 74 million
votes you've got people that are looking
at Joe Biden I'm not going to call him a
cognitive mess or anything like that
that's very disrespectful I would never
speak about our president that way but
when you're 82 years of age it's not
it's not offensive to say you're no
longer spring chicken and you don't seem
to have the level of five and and the
energy that you want you to have so you
take that into consideration take that
into consideration you can't ignore the
fact that this man is a threat oh make
no mistake I take him as serious as a
heart attack okay um I I'm optimistic
but but we're going to have to fight
tooth and nail and one of the biggest
obstacles we're going to have to
overcome is all the efforts to prevent
people from voting okay uh we're going
to have to turn out our people uh we're
going to have to work like never before
we're going to have to work
our democracy is on the line because it
damn well is right and and I don't so I
I take
this just interject one thing into this
discussion about Trump that we've been
having all night it was a question I was
going to ask you we were in out of time
sure the Atlantic put out an article
last year and it was called separating
Sports by sex doesn't make sense right
and talked about how we separate sports
like the wnb just because it's just
socialization this is insane I agree
okay that's why people vote for Trump
because there's stuff like that on the
left that people just go uh I know
Trump's horrible but separating by
Sports by sex makes perfect sense and if
you think it doesn't uh you can't lead
the country but that's cutting off your
nose to spite your faith okay I'm just
I'm just giving you the answer to the
question you're asking all night long
why do they vote for Donald Trump it's
not always because they like him it's
because stuff like that is cookier to
them okay as you can see we played
longer version of the clip there when
they got into the separating stuff by
sex because I'm trying to illustrate
that there was a sane liberal position
which Bill Mah still tries to hold on to
for again for all his faults and
everything else and I know every time I
give him credit people get pissed at me
it's okay um that was there were sane
positions but now you have the decent
liberal the sane liberal the only one
because Adam ship is a progressive
lunatic and Seth McFarland is also a
progressive lunatic saying there is a
reason people vote for Trump Bill's
going I'm not gonna vote for Trump I
don't like Trump I always make fun of
Trump trump makes fun of me we fight all
the time but like there's a sane
position here now as for Stephen A Smith
and the original purpose of the uh of
the clip first off when Stephen A says
this thing about I'm not going to
disrespect the office by talking about
his mental state and then he says you
know he's no spring chicken it's like
I'm not disrespecting the Office of the
President when I tell you that there is
something wrong with Joe Biden I'm
actually respecting it I want the
president to have some level of
cognitive ability I want the president
to not sound like he is about to K over
and get confused in the middle of
sentences and be able to read properly
offered teleprompter and not make up
words and and make up stories about his
past because I care about America
because I care about the office of the
presidency so I think Stephen A all due
respect I think you got it slightly
backwards there as for ship who is just
so freaking Shifty he is Shifty shift
Trump I'll give Shifty ship I'll give
you credit on that nickname Trump um the
idea that Republicans are the ones who
don't want people to vote is complete
nonsense Republicans generally want
people to show an ID when you vote which
you have to do in the State of Florida
versus when I lived in California and
they and when I accidentally because it
was by default went to show the guy my
ID he kind of freaked out we want secure
elections nobody is stopping anyone from
a Val with a valid ID from voting the
idea that black people somehow can't get
IDs is deeply racist it's the soft
bigotry of low expectations and I'm
fairly certain I've seen black people on
planes has everyone in this room seen a
black person on a plane black people
even Snakes on a Plane what's name he's
black